première chose sur euh les sanctions qui
sont euh émises par le bureau nous
sommes un collectif humain dans tout
collectif humain il y a des règles et
nous n'avons pas pour habitude de
communiquer sur les sanctions qui sont
faites à partir du moment où c'est
public nous avons donc communiqué sur
cette question avec euh un communiqué du
Bureau que vous avez pu euh avoir ù tout
est dit dans ce communiqué du bureau je
voudrais m'insurger contre deux choses
fausses qui sont dites la première qui
expliquerait que Madame Raquel garido a
été sanctionnée de la même manière que
Adrien catnin je rappelle que monsieur
Adrien catnins a été exclu du groupe
parlementaire pendant 4 mois et que là
nous parlons pour madame garidau de un
de la question d'oratrice de groupe
c'est-à-dire de ne pas avoir une
question au gouvernement c'est de ça
dont on est en train de parler et de pas
de ne pas être oratrice du groupe pour
les DG les explications de vote et lesé
motion mais qu'elle continue d'être
membre du groupe de pouvoir participer
aux réunions du groupe de porter des
amendements bref de faire son travail
parlementaire tout à fait normalement la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il est faux de
dire que Madame garido aurait été
sanctionné pour avoir critiqué ou pour
avoir juste exprimé ses idées euh mais
pour des accumulations d'agissement et
de propos répétés qui nuisent au bon
fonctionnement du groupe notamment je
vous relis ce que nous avons écrit la
diffusion de fausse information dans la
presse à propos du groupe ou de ses
membres la mise en cause et le
dénigrement annominê de plusieurs
membres du groupe la prise à partie de
salariés du groupe parlementaire voilà
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait
d'avoir exprimé oui ou non des idées ou
des critiques